[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello everybody I'm Doug cockle though
you might know me best from CD projekt
Red's beloved Witcher Trilogy Where I
voice
the original bath taking monster Slayer
geralt of Rivia
now we've got a great show for you today
but I'm not hosting it alone oh no now
I'd like to introduce you to somebody
who's been with Gerald through thick and
thin from mountains High to valleys low
and the occasional thatched roof
of course I'm referring to the
incomparable
gravity-defying roach wait a second you
thought that you were hosting a video
game Showcase with a horse
I was a little confused when they sent
me the brief but this actually makes a
lot more sense
lovely to see you again Denise hello
everyone my name is Denise Goff and I
voice the powerful sorceress Jennifer or
wingerberg in The Witcher 3. but today
this is the future game show powered by
Mana and we're going to treat you to
over an hour of exclusive trailers for
upcoming video games and you'll be able
to find and wish list all of the games
from today's show on the future game
show steam page and you can head on over
to gamesradar.com to read more about
them let's kick things off with our
first world premiere shall we
quietly from the creation that we are
most proud of
that was Outpost which is a working
title wish lists at the ready as it's
coming soon to PC
next up we've got a psychological horror
game that explores grief and loss in a
familiar environment
Peggy 18.
so there's an old saying about this
place called hell where bad people go to
after the dead have to die
but the worst part about hell is not the
flames it's the hopelessness
[Music]
and I think that
is the part of hell
that a person is impression
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Pluto is coming to Playstation and PC in
2022
now here's inflection games Aaron Flynn
to tell you more about the Studio's
debut game Nightingale
[Music]
ever since the day the portal Network
collapsed stranding Us in these realms
we have searched for a way home
hello I'm Aaron Flynn CEO of inflection
games the developer of Nightingale a
shared world survival crafting game set
in a rich Gaslamp fantasy Universe you
may have seen our latest Gameplay
trailer during summer game Fest Live
this week in that footage we revealed
the realm card system a key mechanic in
our game that allows players to access
the portal Network and explore the
magical Fey realms we want to take this
opportunity today to walk you through
how the system works in a little bit
more detail as a realm Walker stranded
into mysterious and deadly New World the
realm cards are a way to access other
Realms players craft realm cards using
magical materials they find in the
environment and those cards are then
used to activate portals which will then
connect you to one of the many possible
Realms that exist in the Fey Universe
each card has different properties like
modifiers that determine different
elements of the realm that players
connect to whether that's new
environments the types of creatures
weather patterns or how rich in a
particular resource a rail might be
players can combine multiple cards
expanding the possibilities of each new
destination
in creating the realm card system we not
only wanted to offer a way for players
to discover everything that the Realms
have to offer but also Empower players
with the ability to influence and
control the nature of the Realms that
they explore
this paired with a sophisticated
procedural generation system makes the
possibilities for adventure across the
Fey Realms almost Limitless
we love the choice this offers players
and no shortage of combinations to
experiment with and learn
will you find a realm overrun with
dangerous creatures or a tranquil place
where you can catch your breath will it
be filled with abundant natural
resources or will it be dark and
battered by storms where a lantern is
your only source of light we're so
excited to see how players explore all
the possibilities that realm cards have
to offer and what incredible new
destinations they may unlock on their
Journey we hope this becomes a Gateway
for players to discover endless
Adventures within the world of
Nightingale thank you for your time for
more information on realm cards head to
play nightingale.com
foreign
think but this
[Music]
and all is mended
[Music]
proof that you should never trust
portals Nightingale is coming to PC
Early Access in Q4 2022
okay World premiere time here's the next
game from the team that brought you the
delightful Co-op Puzzler Foggs
now
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anyway
that was Trey Racers which is coming to
PC and Nintendo switch in 2023 next up
we have an update from our friends at
quali about their growing lineup of PC
and console games let's see what they've
got
product not yet rated
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no
no
no no
[Music]
no no no no
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
that was your first look at wildmender
and robobeat what's next Denise how
about an explosive roguelite where you
play as not one but four blade-wielding
badasses I am sold
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ly that was the work of just one
developer morbid metal is coming soon to
PC
you know Doug I think golf is just too
relaxing these days it's like tee up hit
it onto the green get a hole in one all
that jazz it's just too easy I think I
have the perfect solution for you and it
involves disco balls and flying cars
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
turbo golf racing which is launching
into Early Access on August 4th there's
also a demo available right now on Steam
and Xbox so be sure to check it out
after the show
I feel like you're being watched Doug
I mean we are on a live stream right now
I just feel like my whole life is being
directed ah I wouldn't worry about it
cue the sun I mean run the trailer
now in its 55th season
American Arcadia broadcast Live 24 hours
a day seven days a week on every digital
platform
Trevor Hills welcome to inax Gemini
Towers you've been working with us for
nine years welcome to Arcadia I've heard
of futuristic city where all the
citizens enjoy a life of luxury and
comfort unaware that they are being
broadcast Live 24 7. Arcadia is not an
ordinary City but the most watched media
phenomenon on the planet where a drop in
popularity comes at the highest cost
that what Gus is dead
what on Earth
[Music]
foreign
I need to get close to the cameras and
upload the loop footage from my cell
phone
but I have to be sure the Right video is
uploaded to the right camera we tell the
story of two characters one of them is
living inside the Arcadia that this has
City where everything is perfect but
it's just a lie travel is just an
average person living a mundane life but
the problem is since he's living inside
a TV show that is not interesting for
the audience it doesn't make him popular
the ratings are not working
and the TV show just wants to take care
of him so when he realizes the that
everything was a lie his life changes
totally that's the moment when he is
going to escape
um
[Music]
foreign
we want to tell is that you don't need
to live just for getting likes on on
Instagram or other social networks just
do the things that make you happy and
you don't need to care about what the
others think control subject on the run
on camera 4025 interrupt broadcast
immediately
foreign
thanks to out of the blue games for that
exclusive insight into the dark side of
reality TV in American Arcadia which is
coming soon
now if you've ever wondered what life
was like for Optimus Prime before he got
famous then our next trailer has all the
answers
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's up Doug oh my bad I was just
booking a trip to Alaska for free gas
we're pleased to announce that a demo
for Alaskan truck simulator is out now
and the game is coming to PC and
consoles in Q4 2022.
hello everybody I'm Doug cockle now you
may know me best from CD projekt Red's
beloved Witcher Trilogy wait why are we
back at the start I've just been playing
with this weird device that the
developers of our next game sent me want
me to press this other button and see
what it does no no let's just uh roll
the trailer
[Music]
that's sorted anything else warning the
current temperature of Earth is
approaching 100 million degrees Celsius
oh great
great puzzles are the most efficient way
of generating entropy energy as an
entropy Center employee the continued
existence of this station and Earth
depends on your energy generation
[Music]
that he survived
thanks Astra
[Music]
okay so solve puzzle brain hurts
generate energy
then rewind Earth exactly
[Music]
foreign
that was the entropy Center which is
coming to PC and consoles in 2022
next up we've got a special presentation
from some incredible Ukrainian
developers games development can be
challenging at the best of times and
with the ongoing conflict we wanted to
highlight and celebrate the incredible
work they continue to do let's take a
look
foreign
[Music]
at 5 00 am our cities were bombed
the war drastically changed game
development during the first months of
war the work on the game was mostly
stopped
we sleep in shifts and regular air raid
alerts have made us move to our
Apartments hallway pretty much
permanently
[Music]
my teammates Ruslan and kusu have spent
a week inside Hawking Metro covering
from never ending airstrikes and had to
reach the city Railway Station by
underground tunnels to evacuate
[Music]
hey everyone I'm Alex from weasel token
an indie Duo based in P if Ukraine our
current project is a peaceful puzzle
Adventure called puzzles for clef the
storm's premise is quite simple
following an invitation from your sister
a young bunny girl named clef travels to
the sky island of their ancestors to
participate in a huge treasure hunt but
of course there would be some
interesting tweets for those willing to
dig deeper
gameplay wise he'll get to explore the
island with tons of Secrets all over the
place silver variety of fossils and
different cute and green sequel locals
from time to time you'll also need to
learn and play some special Melodies
that influence the world around you we
would really appreciate it if you
followed weasel talking on social media
Twitter Instagram Facebook please
wishlist and follow puzzles for class on
Steam that helps a lot also join us on
our Discord server we always enjoy
talking to our fellow gamers
my name is Vitali and I represent Marvel
Collective together we are working on
zero losses
short open world driving game with
horror elements and Hollow atmosphere
zero losses is our inevitable reaction
to the un's surrounding us while most
games about war focus on action and
combat we wanted to bring a different
perspective filled with oppressive dark
atmosphere showcasing the unsetting
aftermath of the Modern Warfare you can
follow us on Twitter and YouTube look
for Marvel Collective
hi everyone I'm marginal act and I'm
working on this train will never end
this rhino never end is a Noir Adventure
detective when you click game about a
cat detective who tried to solve the
murder of ex-mayor of the sunny City and
also tries to solve the mystery of
never-ending downpour can subscribe to
my social networks Twitter Instagram
also you can visually Instagram will
never end thank you very much glory to
Ukraine hello world my name is Andrei
bujkowski I'm indie game developer
originally from Kiev together with a
small team I'm working on the turn-based
Mars colony City Builder called
ferlanders in my games I'm always trying
to make some Unique Mechanics to stand
out except for Colony building the core
mechanic in the game is terraforming
also in the game you can learn new
technologies trade with other colonies
and explore underground caves so to
summarize if for Landers seems like your
cup of tea which listed on steam or try
out for Landers prologue which is
already available for free
hi my name is Albert conier I am the
developer of the indie games Frozen
nightmares those nightmares is Hardcore
platformer about salmon that travels in
the mysterious and writing in the world
of the children nightmares the player
will have to overcome All Children's
fears and fight with the almighty God of
Dreams Marvels if you want to support us
visit our steam page at the game to
yogish list plays a demo and give us
your feedback in any possible way
foreign
ar.com for more information on our games
for Ukraine presentation and a list of
Charities that would welcome your
support
if you like the animation series Gravity
Falls or Over the Garden Wall you're
going to love our next game lost in play
is a puzzle Adventure that follows two
siblings lost in their own imagination
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
s on PC and Nintendo switch on August
10th 2022.
you know what we're approaching the
midpoint of the show and I could kill
for a nice refreshing drink is there any
redanian lager lying around spoken like
a true Witcher we don't have any real
beer but this next trailer is sure to
quench your thirst
foreign
[Music]
that's cool
[Music]
I think that's done the trick brewmaster
is coming to PC and consoles in 2022
with a demo available right now on Steam
next let's check out an exclusive
trailer for Bramble the Mountain King a
puzzle platformer heavily inspired by
Nordic folklore
hello everyone my name is Eleanor and
I'm the lead artist at doomfrost studio
and today I will introduce one of our
creatures that you'll meet on your
journey in Bramble the Mountain King a
grim Adventure based on dark Nordic
fables
making is just one of our favorite
creatures from Nordic folklore found in
cautionary tales meant to scare children
from going to close to the water
in Bramble nekin is a lonely creature
living in a lake luring people with his
music so enchantedly that they would
drown
in his past life it was just a simple
man who loved playing his violin
unfortunately the village didn't
appreciate his talent and people would
frequently bully him
the only soul that didn't was a girl
that naked fell in love with
one day the bullying and beating became
so severe that nicken's anger finally
overtook him
he marched into the village playing
forbidden Melodies that made everyone
dance until their flesh and Bone got
burned down
they eventually died leaving behind
shuffling corpses still trying to dance
to napkins melodies
SLA wasn't spared to death either
devastated neck and left the town and
lived by the Lake drowning in his sorrow
luring people with his deadly music
Ian is just one of the creatures you'll
meet and bramble the Mountain King you
will meet many more both big and small
Good and Evil on your journey throughout
the beautiful yet deadly world of
Bramble
Bramble the Mountain King is coming soon
to PC and consoles be sure to add
Bramble to your wish list thank you for
watching
[Music]
I'm Noah mecker when I see one Bramble
the Mountain King is coming soon to PC
and consoles
okay now I'm no mobster but I've got an
offer that you can't refuse in the form
of a world premiere
[Music]
into people with money
and those who want to get it at any cost
and in the middle of this conflict are
also those who just fight on one side or
the other
unknown heroes or villains
choices can be written on the pages of
one story or another
the best way to get rich is sometimes
each
other
will be the fight for
[Music]
the Enemy of the State
Enemy of the State is coming to PC and
consoles in 2024.
now we've had so many amazing trailers
but I think it's time for a break
tea coffee
ale oh I've got something better than
tea you just have to follow me through
one of my portals no need to be afraid
though we have done this before
this never ends well for me
oh my God where am I
it's so bright
and what's that smell
lilac and gooseberries uh no Doug this
is the virtual show floor every booth in
here has a game attached with a demo
going live after the show Google future
games show steam to find the dedicated
page and try out any of the games you
like the look of let's go just when you
thought you'd had enough of being
tarnished this year we've got a fantasy
RPG set in the ruins of two Divine
kingdoms the tarnishing of juxtia
features awesome boss battles high risk
High reward combat and a beautiful score
to boot it's also launching later this
year in summer 2022 what's next Denise
from one ruined Kingdom to another let's
take a look at the grimdark World Of
Orcs a blend of Tower Defense and deck
building gameplay Orcs invites players
to fortify castles and expand their
territory while fighting against an
onslaught of you guessed it Orcs with
over 300 cards and four factions to play
with Orcs is coming to PC later this
year
over here we've got a point and click
inspired by the LucasArts Classics let's
check in on a twisted tail with
hand-drawn backgrounds and a catalog of
comical characters this old school
Adventure will have you giggling and
traveling to Broken cities Mighty pirate
ships deep jungles and more inspired by
games like slay the spire and monster
train here comes a rock and roll
roguelite where players use musical
abilities to fend off a mosh pit of
monsters this diverse deck builder is a
bona fide Battle of the Bands where you
assemble a team of vicious virtuosos to
defend against hordes of demons
reptilian Rising is a turn-based tactics
game where you take on a barbaric horde
of lizards and futuristic robot
dinosaurs fighters from across time are
recreated in a retro miniature format in
a true homage to the tabletop style of
the 1980s reptilian Rising features
multiple replayable levels with lots of
bonus objectives and you can also
challenge fellow players in Online PVP
to see which tactician ends up on top
think less I am the danger and more I am
the Savior potion permit is a cute
chemist simulator from massive media
with Rich pixel art and a soaring score
you'll gather ingredients to brew
precious remedies that help the
townsfolk of moonbury pack your Satchel
because potion permit is coming to PC
and console in 2022
next up we've got a gorgeous rhythm game
set in a world where dreams and reality
Collide melatonin from half asleep games
hits players in a pastel world where
they must unravel a narrative by
engaging in Charming challenges
complemented by a bouncy vibrant score
next up we've got a musical Adventure
about two best friends trying to make it
in the big city Once Upon A Jester
follows Jester and sock as they try to
develop a dynamic improvisational
theater show worthy of the royal
theatrical spectacle decide your genre
listen to the crowd and make valuable
friends in this handcrafted Lo-Fi
Odyssey if you've ever wanted to play
tag in a graveyard full of ghouls then
this game is for you Balo jail is a
creepy cute asymmetrical multiplayer
game from Konami players have three
minutes to round up runaway humans or
escape the grasp of malevolent monsters
each with unique abilities and that's a
wrap on the virtual show floor remember
to head to the Future games show steam
page if you want to play these Beauties
after the show free of charge
and just one final reminder that you can
Google future games show steam to
download all those demos after the show
means there's another world premiere on
the horizon
Peggy 18.
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
over here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that was your first look at Sunday gold
which is coming in 2022
our next game is coming to VR platforms
but I doubt you'll be able to keep your
fancy headsets on for too long when
you're playing let's take a look
[Music]
ie
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I'll pick hide please do not open is
coming to VR Platforms in Fall 2022
now it's time for an update on bright
memory infinite fyqd Studios hectic
shooter
Shelia according to info from the front
lines General Lynn's unit has arrived at
the scene General Lynn the top dog
they say that Tech wise even we here at
SRO can't hold a candle to these guys
Roger I'll move cautiously
[Music]
it's been a while Shelia
to think we'd meet like this
once it's all been poured out a new
world will be born
[Music]
all right
but you're too late once I finish
pouring this primordial flood over Earth
the black hole will change the world
respond what happened
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
memory infinite is out now on PC and is
coming soon to Playstation Xbox and
Nintendo switch
next up we've got a Gothic horror
metroidvania that looks like a pixely
version of bloodborne let's check it out
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the last faith is coming to PC and
consoles in 2022
now let's check in with our friends from
Team 17 who have a montage of exciting
upcoming games to show us
Peggy 18.
come on Frank we need to vacate these
premises now
[Music]
[Music]
let's move on straight to our deceased
well who do we have here today
[Music]
[Music]
roses Rose
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
be sure to wish list any games that
stood out and you can read more about
them on gamesradar.com
have you ever wondered what the bugs in
your house are doing when you're out not
really probably just making a mess you'd
be surprised try complex governmental
structures and organized religion at
least that's the brief I've got for
tinykin which is up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the fascinating world of tiny
kid
[Music]
Heineken are extraordinary little
creatures
alone they rarely pose a threat
but in great numbers they are exemplary
[Music]
look here's some now
ah the purple tiny kid
extremely powerful despite their small
stature
look here green time
dreamly resourceful in reaching reaching
daring New Heights
[Music]
stand back unless you want a blue tiny
kin to sap you with a powerful electric
cut
thank you
[Music]
and that's everything
wait what's this
well look
there's Daniel a red tiger kid adorable
with an immensely fiery tamper
[Music]
tinykin is coming to PC Playstation Xbox
and Nintendo switch
you know when you're finished cleaning
but you realize you missed a bunch of
crumbs it's like just when I thought I
was out they pulled me back in yeah it's
like when the boss orders a hit and
you've got to go clean it up after hours
yeah sort of maybe this next game is for
you
[Music]
four people sharing a table on a New
Year's Eve
plate full of troubling memories
bitter taste of regret
[Music]
505 games and draw distance are proud to
present
serial cleaners
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
a story of loyalty
betrayal
and crime
lots of crime the past they share is all
that stands in the way of redemption
thank you
if you remember the 90s differently
their dirty work is the reason why
[Music]
ah so that's how you get wine out of a
carpet serial cleaners is launching in
September on PC Nintendo switch
PlayStation and Xbox
do you ever miss taking your shoes off
in front of strangers and spending your
life savings on a cup of coffee and boy
do we have the simulator for you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to renew your passport
because airport simulator is coming in
to land on PC and Xbox series X and s in
2023
let's break things up with our ones to
watch Montage keep your eyes peeled for
several exciting games that are coming
in the near future and check out this
awesome bespoke introduction from the
team behind in culinati
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
good morning
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
did any of those games turn your head
check out gamesradar.com for more
information
next up we've got a new game from the
minds behind Happy game Amanita design
in phonopolis you'll help Felix solve
playful puzzles in an avant-garde
fiberboard City we couldn't quite work
out how either but what you're about to
see is actual gameplay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
that was funopolis which is coming soon
now we've got a Subterranean roguelike
where you play as a lucid dreamer in a
world of endless slumber
grant us protection from That Hideous
Strength I Guess the Shadow as endless
as a dream we all wither and its shade
succumbing to all manner of Desire
willed into being by The Dream
those who refuse to slake such corrupt
thirst are cast Into the Depths to
languish and solitude
until a voice the strong ensures their
own Whispers in their ear
this dream is ours you need only ask for
what you desire to will it into being
a safe return a better world
simply as
you face me so a lost land requires a
Shepherd what manner of Shepherd are you
wolf
down here
the only one around
don't sleep on being and becoming which
is
becoming soon to PC
our next game follows a pilot who
crashlands in the Arctic after his plane
is chopped in half by mysterious forces
but he also has a court-mandated therapy
robot called Alfie every cloud right
I thought you could hear some company up
here
yeah not really I'm good
[Music]
[Music]
Donovan
Donovan you copy
hey drone wake up
[Music]
I do want to help in any way I can kind
you can help by staying out of it
[Music]
oh thank God I thought I'd lost you was
that Donovan I heard on the radio what
you're spying on me now
[Music]
silos
Power Station maybe
wait Power Station out here
hey Donovan
Donovan you copy
[Applause]
no thermal vision no lasers no useful
functions whatsoever
can you do anything to actually help
I am happy to talk it through with you
uh Doug it's your line again
oh sorry I'm just canceling that trip to
Alaska that was Arctic Awakening which
is coming to PC Mac and consoles in 2023
we've had a lot of fast-paced games in
this showcase but none quite as quick as
our next trailer let's stay on track and
check this one out
this is not a challenge for the
faint-hearted with the 20 best drivers
in the world come together to take on
some of the world's most historic
circuits and that Legacy continues today
it's lights out and away we go
there's not much in it at the front with
the two cars constantly vying for first
place it's a thrilling battle with
neither driver giving an inch
we might still be early in the season
but that doesn't mean we can sit back
and relax everything is up for grabs and
nothing is certain at this stage
[Music]
here we go with the Azerbaijan Grand
Prix
I think we should be satisfied with the
steps here
oh no it's a spin
foreign
this is Formula One
[Applause]
who wants to be in the driver's seat
when you can be in the driver's driver's
seat anyway don't forget to tune into
the PC gaming show to see the first game
play from F1 manager which is racing
onto PC PlayStation and Xbox on August
25th 2022.
put your dukes up folks because this
next game is a certified dko wait what
does that mean uh Divine knockout Doug
the
[Music]
that was divine knockout which is coming
soon
our next game is an adventure epic where
you navigate a world full of tricky
puzzles with the help of your Robo
friend it's true that behind every main
character there's a smart talented
companion to help them get through it
all Denise are you referring to Jennifer
well if the shoe fits here's planet of
Lana
follow me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
ER is coming to PC and Xbox in 2022
this next reveal is a pretty big deal no
spoilers but let's just say I really
didn't see this one coming
[Music]
[Music]
out here our world contains phenomena
that could never be explained with logic
this changes everything
it's time to put our skills to the test
Deadly Premonition 2 is out now on PC
that's right now today this second
go check it out
based on the notes on my script it looks
like the producers were struggling for
jokes on this one there's something
about geralt hunting a Moomin honestly
it's not even worth it this trailer is
adorable and I just need you all to see
it
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
God
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
snuffkin Melody of Moomin Valley is
coming to PCN consoles in 2023 with a
soundtrack from Icelandic post-rock band
sigur Ross
last but not least we've got a brand new
Multiplayer Survival game that fans of
Pokemon are sure to enjoy let's check it
out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can't wait to check that one out well it
looks like we're at the end of the show
it's been an honor Doug check the back
of your script I think we missed
something okay do you also have one more
thing Written in Blood is that normal
yes I do and no this is not normal
I'm gonna go sharpen my silver sword
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
now that really is the end of our show
but remember to try out all the demos on
our future game show steam page and head
on over to gamesradar.com for more
follow-up coverage on all of the games
that you've seen today I'd like to say a
big thank you to everyone involved in
this year's future games show powered by
Mana and of course you guys watching at
home I'm Doug cockle and I'm Denise Goff
and this has been the future game shows
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
survived
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you